it's one of the most influential and
controversial social networks today but
for years struggled to moderate content
and make money then one of the world's
richest men stepped in to some he was
the knight in shining armor to others he
was Twitter's worst nightmare
official Elon Musk has agreed to buy
Twitter for 44 billion dollars Twitter
down 11 after musk filed to walk away
from that merger agreement there's two
kind of dramatic outcomes that could
come from this legal battle Twitter is
now officially owned by Elon Musk and
the news is still sinking in oh welcome
okay to our customer support At Your
Service we've got the expenses
reasonably under control so the
company's not like in the fast lane of
bankruptcy anymore and releasing
features uh faster than Twitter's
history at the same time Elon Musk is
going to transition away from his CEO
role into an executive chairman role
these days everyone has an opinion on
Twitter so I wanted to get some
perspective from its original Architects
and these people no Twitter better than
almost anyone
obviously it's a huge story that people
have been fascinated with for a year now
so right well years well here we go
should my feet be off the ground like a
little kid
let's just start with like tell me who
you are and your what was your role
should we do each other instead yes so
this is Jason at Goldman on Twitter
Jason worked
with me on Blogger we got acquired I
left Google Jason took over blogger but
then we did Twitter he's like I'm in you
guys have been friends for a really long
time indeed yes and so Evan Williams uh
was uh the Creator and founder of
blogger and then the doc crash happened
um and EV kept it alive essentially
through force of will yeah started Odo
and uh then Twitter was spun out and he
eventually became CEO of Twitter and was
on the board so there's been a lot of
changing of the guards at Twitter when
Elon burst onto the scene
were you both just like what yeah it was
surprising I mean I'm trying to remember
the first bursting on or if I was even
aware of it were you the idea that he
was going to buy the company to me
initially saying like oh he's not going
to be really serious about this it's
going to be uh like the way you sort of
you know put in a reservation on like a
fancy sports car there have been a
couple moments where I'm like oh I
started this thing
with some other people a long time ago
in this little office
and then
the world's richest man bought it right
and it's this big news story like how
did how did that happen that's weird was
there any part of you that was like oh
this is interesting maybe it's a little
exciting yes I like interesting things
to happen right I'm not a fan of things
staying the way they are I mean that's
why we do Tech that's why we start new
things Twitter had been getting better
and better actually the trajectory of
improvements in the year or two uh prior
to Elon but then I was like Elon my holy
holy moly he does crazy things this will
be interesting and fun we'll see what
happens
yeah
we may differ on this point
yeah I mean I I was just concerned
because like everything he was talking
about that he wanted to do with the
product seemed pretty lightly considered
we gotta defeat all the Bots and you
know we there's all the stuff about like
the culture wars but it became clear
over time no that is his primary
interest in owning the platform is the
kind of push on these particular
cultural uh issues and his own personal
use of the product he wants to make
better so how do you feel about what
he's done so far
I don't think he's dialed it in quite
right yet well it's gone pretty poorly I
mean I'm just objectively speaking the
moves fast sort of Mythos is blighed by
that most of the things that have been
pushed out the door like Twitter blue or
view counts make sure you amplify my
tweets so that everyone sees them uh
which is again if you own the product
you can do that it's just a curious way
to product manage a global platform for
years Twitter was criticized for not
innovating fast enough not making enough
money struggling to get users did
something have to happen
my main feedback that I recall giving on
board is
we need to do more things more
Innovation more bigger Bolder bets
that's much easier said than done a lot
of that effort though was going towards
making the platform more safe and
dealing with a lot of things have been
overlooked for a long period of time
including you know harassment abuse like
manipulation by non-state actors you're
talking about real problems that they
had to clean up and deal with
um so I I respect the fact that they
spent a lot of time on that as opposed
to shipping new features and given what
we know now about how 2022 played out
economically something probably would
have happened right you know it's
unlikely that Twitter would have just
sailed through without massive layoffs
without some sort of activist interest
in the company Twitter was in a
vulnerable state I just don't think it
needed to be uh quite this silly is
there something about his hardcore
approach that's shaking the valley up
well I think the fact that interest
rates are going up and there's the
greatest economic downturn for the
industry since 2000 has more to do with
why the industry has choking up
um and I don't think that Facebook and
Google are doing massive layoffs because
they saw that Elon could get people to
sleep on the floor there is a
particularly among like the VC world
this hunger for this era of austerity
which is like employees with their free
kombucha and all of their lattes and all
this stuff like that everyone wants
these goddamn lattes they're running us
out of business
can't sell enough ads for this kombucha
on tap and and like now that air is over
and you know people are gonna have to
buckle down the tables have turned the
austerity of Silicon Valley begins Jack
Dorsey who co-founded Twitter with you
said Twitter is the closest thing we
have to a global Consciousness solving
for the problem of Twitter being a
company Elon is the singular solution I
trust this is one of the worst age
tweets of all time like I mean like this
is this is honestly one of the worst
tweets that's ever been put on the
platform and there's a lot of them Jack
has been very consistent on this from
the beginning is that he really was
interested in Twitter as a protocol like
a public good that could be used uh in
the same way that Civic infrastructure
exists the problem was with Twitter is
that we were inherently not building a
public good we were building a
for-profit Enterprise I had debates when
I was running the company with Jack and
other people in the company about
whether Twitter could or should be that
and I think Jack agrees at this point
that once it was we took Venture Capital
it couldn't be that what I think is
interesting and exciting is that it's
opened up a space for potentially other
platforms or other protocols to emerge
and people may pay attention to them
because Twitter maybe has less of a
gravitational force for everybody's
attention there are a lot of folks out
there who are angry at Jack like I think
some folks feel like Jack's fed Twitter
to the elong wolves do you feel that at
all or
I I do uh like the I mean if you look at
the timeline of how the deal was put
together it's pretty clear that Jack was
instrumental I'm not mad at Jack I think
he made a mistake I mean he cares so
deeply and he did the decision he
thought was correct I'm guessing it's
not going the way he was hoping in fact
Dorsey admits it it all went South
so let's take the other part of the
Tweet what is Twitter is Twitter the
global town square is it the global
Consciousness in your view oh gosh no we
have a global Consciousness it's not
Twitter I think that's not right it's
conceptually sort of like oh let's
connect all the people
in the world and have a communication
mechanism even at Google
with the best technologist in the world
people who are building the bleeding
edge of the internet in early 2000s
those people including the founders
fundamentally did not understand that
the web was a platform for
self-expression
yeah so this is an old version of Larry
Bird
um in which she had like Larry the Bird
if you realize the bird was named Larry
the bird's name Larry yeah 2007. you
guys get to South by Southwest are you
is this like what are you feeling it's
just like oh my God we just created this
and we're gonna change the world
yes
there was a time in which having a cell
phone was not a sufficient condition to
know what your friends were doing the
memory lane thing is so interesting
because there's so much history that's
intertwined with world history I mean
could you even pick like if what fave
tweets of all time
plane landing in the Hudson Lane in
Hudson's is a good one plane landing in
the Hudson broke on Twitter and that was
what fave celebrity onboarding moments I
got invited on Oprah hi it's Friday live
and I'm on Twitter for the first time
sitting next to me is Evan Williams the
co-founder of Twitter can you believe
all this tweedly D stuff going on
the plan was I would talk about Twitter
she asked me a couple questions and
she'd send her first tweet on air and
then she hit the key with the yellow
tape on it which doesn't sound situate
it didn't send the Tweet the Tweet went
away yeah and uh then they kept the
commercial and so when they're at
commercial I typed in her tweet you
impersonated Oprah is basically what
we're learning yeah
another memorable one was the Dalai Lama
who supposedly he wanted to be on
Twitter and it was super awkward he's
delightful obviously but it felt like I
was there to sell him on Twitter and and
I said oh so we're gonna you know get
you on he's like
I don't need that
but I was told that's why worry I
thought this was all sold through
already this was pre-iphone I think yeah
and so we got his account all set up so
we just gave him the Blackberry and then
he used this account or with one of his
people used this account for years but
my wife and I paid the bill the
Blackberry so we were paying Dalai
Lama's cell phone bill for a very long
time do you know how like the shortcut
to Nirvana that you get by virtue of
having the Dalai Lama on your friends
and family plan has to be has to be
amazing
this was a way of using the web as this
portal into other people's experiences
and other people's lives well this is
the hardest question right like what
makes it amazing also makes it a
cesspool yeah and how do you keep the
best without the worst right there is a
view that the problem with centralized
platforms or for-profit platforms is
they they take all the money that all
the people create but Twitter in its
history has never made money like
there's been profitable years but
overall
there's no money I mean I've made money
I mean thank you but
um in to some extent platforms once they
reach a certain scale do kind of work
like governments you have to have rules
and you have to enforce rules I believe
or else you have Anarchy and in some
sense regulation has been trying to
catch up so you were the white house
chief digital officer do you think
Twitter should be regulated oh
definitely the type of Regulation I
think is almost inarguable that anyone
ought support is just greater
transparency on how these things work
there is this naive perception similar
to the money making thing which is that
these companies will do anything to
twist the knobs to squeeze a few more
dollars the reality is that no one
running these companies actually
understands what's going on that well I
mean like these are we're talking about
stochastic systems that are amplifying
content according to a set of rules that
some human wrote but the output of those
rules is unpredictable increasingly some
human didn't write the rule yeah exactly
exactly and so you don't even know you
don't even know what people are seeing
or why why we including the people who
built these systems can't confidently
say they understand the effect of what
they've built people outside have no
idea the complexity and the
thoughtfulness that goes into these
decisions about what can stay on it
reminds me of different metaphors you're
like you're like hosting a party yeah
yeah and like someone's ruining the vibe
yeah if you want to have a good party in
a good environment you need to make it
comfortable and safe for everybody but
you you try to do that for the whole
world and then it gets very hard and
it's very very nuanced and I believe you
want to host a good party not just say
like do whatever you want on the streets
we just paved the streets and that's all
we do how do you feel right now looking
at something that you created kind of
going through this I'm very Zen but
I I was
sad when the purchase actually went
through I was like oh I no longer own
any Twitter and I really felt for the
people who were there who when you know
had a lot of turmoil and lots of really
great people but maybe we just had the
wrong idea with Twitter now it's time to
move on to some other idea
some other ideas that musk has moved on
to
a tick tock inspired for you timeline a
new color-coded verification system he's
gotten rid of Legacy check marks and of
course Twitter Inc the company doesn't
even exist anymore it's now called
x-corp
even some Twitter employees still on the
inside admit it's a work in progress
as those now on the outside continue to
process what it was like being in the
eye of the storm
so give me some snapshots over the
course of the Deal or No Deal roller
coaster what was happening inside the
company it felt like the company was
kind of uh Frozen uh you know it was not
the most productive uh six months with
the company even though the company
feels or felt internally like there
wasn't a lot going on the rest of the
world was buzzing so I would head into
headquarters and my manager was saying
um be careful because there were people
out there that are wearing body cams it
was as if everybody just wanted a piece
of the pie I think we didn't really know
if it was really ever going to really
happen until the last minute yeah it was
just such a roller coaster and it felt
like a bad Netflix series but a lot of
it unfolded on Twitter too like a lot of
Twitter's culture is using products the
deal happens Elon Musk owns Twitter
were any of you inside the company the
day he walked in with the sink I wish I
had oh my God I wish I I was Manu you
are we were the resident cartoonist
you gave your new boss a cartoon that
was kind of making fun of him I picked
one that would not be uh perceived as
boot licking not being too kind but I
didn't want one that was so critical
that would she would find me on the spot
it was a very twittery
um you know response from you you break
it you buy it
um explain it because he was damaging
the company in many ways like the stock
was going up and down and it was just
chaos so I thought you know if you you
break the company in a way like the
culture even from the outside so now you
have to buy it what kind of
communications did you have with Elon
himself or his team what were they
telling you to do there were these
Lifeboat projects where Elon would just
you know in a random meeting say an idea
and all of a sudden that was one of the
directives
um top Prime directives for the company
to work on yeah that explains why I was
reviewing so much documentation from
teams and projects I've literally never
heard of until that day I think it's a
very common
um toxic management technique to keep
people in very tight deadlines so they
never have time to think at some point I
made a very simple tool to help people
save some of their documents things that
would be useful for future employment
and then I was fired one hour later I
mean I was in meeting I was in a meeting
for some high priority Elon will have to
be done by yesterday so this project and
I was just disconnected from the meeting
we all received an email saying that the
next morning you would receive one of
two emails one that would either go to
your personal email telling you that
you're no longer with the company or to
your work email saying that you know
you're still at the company for a lot of
us it would be our last day at Twitter
um and for me it was people just were
putting the salute Emoji into uh one of
the company-wide slack channels and yeah
it was sort of amazing to watch that all
all sort of happening at once now this
is like four days before the election
and Helen said you were working on
Election misinformation I I was I had so
many windows open that day I need to
monitor like midterm elections trying to
connect with different teams and I
checked the VPN VPN is logged out and
that's how I found out that I had lost
access and was no longer a part of the
company and I know I worked remotely but
I think that was truly one of the times
where I felt the most alone Sean you
lasted longer than anyone yeah and then
you decided to resign I'm not the kind
of person to have an illusion about
company where you find my like soul
mates or like you know devote like I
guess I don't identify my core being
with the company the way like layoffs
were done there was like no like like
Grace to it like two weeks later he sent
an email uh basically like you know on
ultimatum to Twitter employees like you
have two options one you stay at Twitter
2.0 and it were extremely hardcore two
get some servants and like get lost and
I was like this is my exit ticket
turn down the hardcore approach I'm not
very hardcore
how many people does it actually take to
keep Twitter up and running at some
point tour is a companion everyone was
making fun of because Twitter went down
all the time being aware but then
Twitter did a lot of good job uh making
things stable and there was like a lot
of like Innovative Technologies like
Twitter um like invented it came up with
and I think it's a testament to the
existing Engineers who who wrote very
robust systems you know some things can
probably get done faster because there's
sort of less management bureaucracy and
layers and things like that I had a
former co-worker at Google who said
something like their their product
shipment strategy is constipated
so does that make Elon Musk like a big
laxative or something
pound Square
would be held to
a jewel I agree in on the internet and
in the world and uh there's nothing
quite like it there's these other
platforms and you can go there but I
think having a single space where you
know you can tweet it you're a congress
person and you know there's there's a
good chance they'll see it and there's a
chance they'll reply and things like
that that's not happening on Facebook
that's not happening on Instagram that's
not happening on Tick Tock I think it is
important that there be some some sort
of Public Square on the internet
does Twitter survive this well we tried
to kill the product a lot I mean we we I
mean it didn't work very well for a
while when we were working there so I
mean there seems to be anti-fragile but
I it'll survive I mean things things
that big don't die Yahoo is still a
company Myspace is still a thing so
you're preparing Twitter to Yahoo yeah I
think that's fine I mean maybe it's
thriving
but reputationally it's very different
does the brand recover
I think that's hard I think brand
recovery is much harder and now the
brand is very linked to Elon should it
be a company yeah should the internet be
a company no and guess what anyone can
make a new Twitter or a better Twitter
or like it's just a whole new paradigm
on the internet and lots of people are
trying right now and that's really cool
I sure I assure your optimism which is
rare for me uh but like you know because
you know we're in like a really bad
market right now and that's when the
coolest stuff has always happened I mean
we met up in the the post dot crash era
right
um and we were like in a detective's
office on Market Street like you know it
was like there was no one was building
companies in San Francisco the other
thing that drives me possibilities is is
platform Evolution and there hasn't been
one in a long time in Tech the last
platform Evolution was the mobile
Revolution and the cloud computing
Revolution and it's been a for in terms
of tech just a very long time since
those and you know it's a long time by
how thirsty the industry is to believe
in any anything else like like please
let it be web3 please let it be the VR
goggles there's got to be some new land
out there
um and now like everyone believes it's
going to be Ai and in that one at least
as opposed to the other two looks like
it might be something like you can do
stuff with it which is and it's getting
better faster which is a good Hallmark
of Technology what about Elon musk's
brand does that recover
yeah I think he's brilliant but no one's
brilliant everything this is one of in
my view silicon Valley's fundamental
sins is is the sin of Genius where you
believe that someone's made a ton of
money must be smart I think the idea of
social media is probably the thing I'm
questioning the most right now yeah for
a minute we thought oh the best would be
a food we like got media from our
friends Tick Tock and some other places
are showing the media from your friends
is probably not as good as the media
from some super talented you know person
who's you've never met before and I
actually think there's tons of
interesting things now if we think about
how do we use the internet to help
people be more social without consuming
or creating media so maybe the future of
social media is the separation of social
and media really interesting what are
the chances that Elon does pull this off
what are the chances he creates a
Twitter that's a better version
yeah I don't know how comfortable Elon
is with losing billions of dollars maybe
is fine maybe he can get to break even
and then just play with it if a hundred
million people in the world share the
most interesting idea or thought and the
computers could algorithmically give you
the most interesting slice of that
that's a hell of a media service but
I also think generally the new thing
does not come from the old thing yeah
tweets I have a weird relationship with
Twitter we all do everyone in the world
I feel like this is maybe this will give
you some closure any advice from old
Twitter to new Twitter
some of the stuff that's trying to come
along to replace Twitter is like this is
going to be a serious place for serious
conversations by serious people and I
don't think that's what attracts a
global audience I don't think that's
what succeeds ultimately it's got to be
delightful I love that point Twitter was
fundamentally founded on humor yeah it
was a bunch of people who like joking
around and they created a new way to
joke so what about what about
Twitter to
my advice for entrepreneurs just
generally is never to underestimate the
role that luck plays in your life we
like in the industry to ascribe success
to like some flash of Brilliance that
people have and those things do happen
but so much of the execution risk comes
down to being lucky and like being in
the right place at the right time at the
right cycle of the platform Evolution
and we're entering a somewhat exciting
phase in which everything is kind of in
Ruins and smoldering and that's should
produce something good right
here's to being in the right place at
the right time yeah maybe getting used
to a new vibe right get lucky new Vibe
should we gaze off into the distance
nearby
[Music]